c'est un jeune papa qui vit seul avec sa
fille parce qu'il a perdu sa femme avec
à cause d'un accident de la route et à
cause du fait qu'elle parlerit au
téléphone en conduisant et du coup ce
jeune papa se retrouve à à vivre avec sa
fille
seul je crois que le simple fait
d'imaginer qu'on a perdu quelqu'un de
d'ussi cher que la mère de son enfant
c'est ça donne assez de matière pour
pour être imprégné de d'émotion
de j'ai moiême des enfants
donc imagin un seul instant un drame
pareil
ça ça inspire en tant qu'acteur
alors ce que j'aime beaucoup dans le
cinéma de remémy c'est c'est la façon
qu'il a de de traiter l'émotion avec il
arrive à à rendre des scènes très
émouvantes sans que ce soit excessif
sans tomber dans le Patos comme on
dit je dirais ben je suis sûr qu'il y a
des gens qui tiennent à toi et qui n pas
envie de te perdre alors va sur Youtube
et regarde ce film regarde ces petits
films et on se rappelle on en parle il
faut pas téléphoner pendant qu'on
conduit quand on voit les statistiques
c'est c'est pas bien c'est très grave il
faut pas il faut pas mourir ça sert à
rien